Oh my gosh I hope oh my god I'm so fucking glad it's over Oh
yeah no that was so nervous and I care it's always the first
karaoke it's always the first karaoke like I'm so nervous
about because like you know I don't know how it's gonna go
and I'm like oh scoff I can't believe I can't believe I kept
crashing in the beginning and then I had to fix it live But
it's like, no!
I'm really happy you guys liked it.
I did get like the copyright stuff, but it was just like,
oh, you can't monetize it.
And I was like, fine, that's fine.
I'm okay with not monetizing it.
I'm okay.
I can keep it up.
It just says like, oh, you just can't monetize it.
I was like, I'm fine with that.
It's alright.
That's why we have an after party here.
and like oh my god i was like re-listening to it are you
guys sure the instrumental was okay i was worried the
instrumental was too loud was it all right was the
instrumental too loud or was it okay i was really i was
really really worried it was too loud i was like
re-listening to i was like oh my god is this too loud can
you guys hear me okay it sounded great really it was fine
okay i trust you guys it was great i trust you guys oh my
god i was like really uh i was really nervous that the
instrumental was like too loud for like too loud compared to
me so i was like oh thank god okay you guys felt like it was
okay anyway that's actually forgot one song i forgot to sing
one song that actually we wanted to like do like as a little
bonus because but then i was like you know i was like oh man
i was so i was so busy you know what maybe this this this
video might not this stream might not be monetized too i
didn't get to use the bathroom okay guys i Because I was
like, just like rewatching everything.
Okay, guys, I'm sorry.
I'm scuffed.
I'm even scuffed now.
I didn't even get to use the bathroom.
I
am back.
I'm back here.
Oh, my God.
I came back and there was fifth.
Oh, my.
Alex, thank you for the fifth to get the chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Came back and there was like 50.
Oh, my God.
Thank you, Alex.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, I was so nervous.
Because like, you know, it was like, first karaoke is always
like the most.
nerve-wracking part and I was like I wish I did my practice
I definitely wish I did practice a little bit more on the
singing but like um there are so many things going on and I
was like so busy that I didn't get a chance to practice as
much as I would love to so I was like stumbling my words I
was stumbling my words a lot and oh I don't know why I can't
breathe now now I can't even breathe I don't why um sorry
for thinking with super chat thank you thank you i'm here on
time this time totally did not oversleep you did great dokey
here here i hope the scuff doesn't get you down and down so
we love you thank you super chat thank you thank you so far
i'm i hope yeah i'm glad you guys enjoyed this scuff i was
like no i'm quashing no oh my god i was like the beginning i
was like really and i realized it was because of the program
i was using the web browser version of Kara fun instead of
the um I was using a web web version instead of like the
program itself I forgot because like it's been so long since
I did a karaoke that I forgot to use the the the actual
program instead of the web browser because the web browser
version overloads my PC because it's like really fucking the
processing for it's like huge and stuff so I forgot about
that and I was like trying to figure out I was like oh my
gosh what do I do and I was like oh my god maybe if I use
the program and then the moment I use the program it stopped
oh my god um and then like but then after that it was okay I
can't believe I had to like redo several signs um but you
guys didn't hear um at 800k subscribers it would be my next
karaoke I will do my next karaoke at 800k subscribers and
then I will tell you guys the production
And, um, and everything will be bigger and better, um, than
the one that we have.
Uh, I will, I blame Canada, 100%.
The amount of time I sang Blame Canada five fucking times.
Four, it was like four fucking times.
That's how, how much hate I have.
It's always Canada's fault.
Like, now thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not VT, Rishi, and welcome.
technical difficulties it's true thank you for the super
chat thank you yeah but i'm such a perfectionist i made you
guys i felt really bad because i made you guys wait 40
minutes too and i was like no you guys waited 40 minutes
youtube Canada and obs all of the above
everything it's not just it's never my fault it's everything
um um but yeah anyway uh so that was that was fun trying to
fucking navigate that i was like it's okay even though even
though i've been streaming for like even though i've been
streaming for like what is it three four year four plus
years now oh actually no like more so like professionally
but like like before that i wasn't like actually
professionally streaming but like even i've been streaming
professionally for like two plus years i i i hope i'm
getting better at streaming i i i hope i'm getting better
streamer and like and like uh the scuff is not as bad like i
hope the scuff was not didn't turn off and the reason why
i'm always like really worried about like scuffed is that
like um it's like i'm worried that that like you know like
basically turn off fans and stuff being like oh i don't want
like turn off like especially new viewers you're like oh i
don't want to watch it there's too too much scuff going on
so i'm always like a perfectionist when it comes to that and
i'm you know like obviously i'm like why can't i fucking
control this like i'm like why can't i control this i like
having control over what's going on on my stream
so i'm just like
um yeah but like uh yeah but i hope like you guys still had
fun and enjoyed it because like the crashing was a little
the crashing i was like uh uh but it was a lot of fun though
um but yes like i said at 800k subscribers it's gonna be a
bigger production value um maybe some custom outfits you
know i think but not like custom not like custom vtuber not
like custom like skin suit outfit but you know like you know
if you remember like last time how big the production was
last time maybe something similar you know he he he maybe
something similar like that uh honestly it was so so big
brain it was really fucking big brain of me to like uh have
like edit it and edit it video and stuff uh to play over it
versus like okay in the past i usually had to like manual i
manual stuff where i like press buttons manually on my
stream deck to like do like the performance you know like
have like random stuff jumping in and out and stuff like
that so i would do that manually on my stream deck i just
still did some today manually uh on my stream deck um but
like i was like you know what bro i could this could be like
even better if i had an editor do this so i was like at my
editors i was like who wants to try it out and then shad um
who's been done who's been like is one of my editors for my
shorts was like was like i can't And then, like, first, we
did, our first video we did was Welcome to the Internet.
And it was so good.
And then, I was like, oh, and then, like, today, I woke.
Okay, I didn't, to be fair, I didn't wake up.
It was more like, I, I, after the JP tournament, I messaged
him.
And I was like, oh, my God, can you also do, like, blame
Canada and friends like me before the stream?
And he's like, this is cutting it real close.
But I'm going to try.
And, like, bro, that guy fucking cried.
Like, he, like, fucking did it.
He got what I wanted in there because I was explaining,
like, my vision.
And then he actually did it before the stream.
To be fair, I did push the stream 40 minutes.
Like, like, we did push the stream 40 minutes.
But, like, it was worth it.
I felt like the weight was worth it, guys.
I felt like the weight was so fucking worth it for, like,
what we had.
Hey, Gio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
days because there's scup is part of the chore and in no way
made the experience bad i love your karaoke talking you're
singing despite what you're saying it's really good thank
you thank you thank you it was super chat to you thank you
thank you i'm really really happy uh uh that you guys really
uh really liked it and i'm i'm super happy because like you
know i was experimenting with this idea you know the the
experimentation of the idea of having a video playing over
it during karaoke and then it makes the karaoke much more
fun um because like you know i don't like doing just
something simple I like to pizzazz it a bit more like yeah
like I know like I'm not the best singer like I know like I
was just like no don't give me love hearing you sing but
come on I know I'm not the best singer okay we don't need a
lie to ourselves I might not be the best fucking singer so
like um I try my best to like you know make it my karaoke is
just a little bit more special of like what you see so like
it's literally like a performance you know like um um like a
performance and uh just like have fun with it and stuff like
that and you know like just have like a fun time like we
were watching me it's like a fun time um and I did have a
lot of fun like uh the um super honestly I know I'm like
fucking patting myself on the back but super to have like,
like, like, edited videos instead of doing the fucking props
and assets stuff, uh, like, by hand, actually super big
brain.
Super, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the karaoke stream, dokey.
Everything stays the same sometimes, even the scuff.
It was Candace's fault for the technical difficulties
keeping me thinking over the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
I think the, the one funny part was the fact that, like, you
know, the, the, the sequel like just ended i was not ready
for that i was like wait that's it because i like listened
to the song but i never listened to the all the way to the
end i was just like wait it just ended i was like okay
that's that's it but honestly like i felt like that song was
like yeah that's me that's the song we're doing a sequel but
a better
We're gonna do it all over again.
We're doing a sequel.
We're back by popular demand.
Come on everybody, strike up the band.
I was like, everybody knows sequels never quite as good.
I definitely had a lot of fun.
Rockstar, thank you very much.
bye thank you thank you it was really fun i'm glad i'm glad
you guys had a lot of fun there was like a song that i did
forgot to do i mean i could okay guys all right i'll give
you guys my treat give me a sec i'm gonna disappear a little
bit my treat guys it was just the right one my treat guys
i'm gone for a little bit but don't worry i promise you guys
uh uh i was like okay i was gonna do this as like a bonus
and then like i forgot about it but i know like a lot of
people demanded it i saw so many people asking for this so i
was like whoops look okay this this stream might not be
monetized as well i might get like striked i don't know how
to sing this song i never practiced it it's been like so
long but i saw so many people were like oh my god please
sing this okay what is it called is this okay i'm just gonna
have the video play with me too because i actually i
actually don't remember this how to sing this song i just
know how to sing like the beginning part
i need to tell you guys i actually don't remember how to
sing this song There we go.
Okay, yeah, wait.
Reverb.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
That's all I remember.
I don't remember how to sing this part.
Oh my god, he sings it so fast I can't read it out.
I can't read this in time.
All right.
.
They sing it too fast, I can't read it in time!
five
from stumbling
it never changed she has never changed
and that's like i don't i can't i stumble so much but that's
like the only part i can actually sing uh
but yes there you go guys here's your here's the meow song
it's called learn to meow um it's a good song that song was
like stuck in my head for so fucking long when i first heard
it um but like even then i could never do like more than the
chorus like i can only i can only do the first chorus that's
it the bgm is no it's too late
I guess this VOD is I guess won't be monetized as well um
your karaoke is cute creative and scuff that's all I can
love thank you so much p.s.
tomato cat is extra cute thank you thank you thank you thank
you and Marcy thank you for this magenta soup but they could
thank you how about yum yum yum yum yum yum yum um that was
like honestly like the only I only remember how to sing the
first because like I can't read fast enough the pingyum like
with the pingyum i was trying to read it try to read it but
like they sing it so fast that my brain was just like what
the fuck i literally i literally can't read the pingyum fast
enough like like the cool kids i can't i'm so bad i can
barely read english let alone like chinese right now i'm too
fucking stupid man um zekran ivy thank you for the magenta
soup you bless uh namo thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank you meow thank you
thank you the super chat thank you thank you but yes i think
i think this stream definitely is gonna get demonetized
because i literally play the song in the background
i turned off my reverb um but yes guys 800k subscribers
remember like and comment and subscribe i feel like an
actual youtuber now like and comment and subscribe if you
love this video and the karaoke remember to like comment and
subscribe so i don't know you know like people be like oh uh
if this if this video hits 500k likes i will do blah blah
blah don't it's not gonna be doing all right if my if my
karaoke bot hits a hundred thousand likes and also and we
hit 800k subscribers we're gonna do another karaoke
does it's so like do people still do this yeah because uh
because of the fucking youtube algorithm um yeah the call to
action it's the smash that like button and hit the
notification bell it's because it's this is the youtube
youtube algorithm people are desperate i'm desperate people
me i'm people um also like by the way guys yeah like karaoke
stuff like i've been like planning it on and off i wish i
did have more time to plan the karaoke i feel like i did
sort of rush into the karaoke a little bit but i really
wanted to have the karaoke like last week because you know i
promised you guys a karaoke before the chair like before the
month was over for march um but then obviously like stuff
happened in the schedule so i had to put it but i didn't
want to delay too much because the charity goal was, the
charity goal was like, oh, I will have the karaoke before
March was over.
So then I was like, okay, all right, we're gonna fucking do
this.
We're gonna do it because I do wish I did have more time to
plan for it due to how busy I've been behind the scenes.
But I did learn a lot.
I did learn a lot regarding planning the charity stuff.
So, not charity stuff, regarding planning this karaoke.
since I'd done karaoke's and done like sang stuff like this
so I still I did that did it because I tried to make sure I
was able to do it just because I wanted to you know make up
for the charity like actually follow through on the charity
goal stuff and so yeah but the real karaoke the real super
karaoke it was just beta we're beta testing chat that was a
beta test to the actual karaoke which would be the 800k
subscriber one like we were beta testing you know like the
the uh was what it is called the where did it call pilot
episode karaoke pilot episode
the karaoke was a pilot episode for for the real karaoke
that's why it was so sc посто you know we're looking for
we're looking for investors to fund the pilot karaoke you
know You know how like, you know, Gravity Falls, the pilot
episode for Gravity Falls and like Bob's Burgers, like all
of that, you could tell it was, it's like not as great, you
know, it's not that good, you know, that was that karaoke,
it was a pilot episode, we're just looking for investors,
we're looking for somebody to fund our future kariokies.
um um can we get a veggie tails theme next karaoke stream
and so you think of the super chat might be funny as the
main voice is a tomato uh veggie tails veggie tails broccoli
that's a palette there you go here's your pilot episode uh
subscribe to fun for the
subscribe to fun for the Subscribe and invest the fun for
the real karaoke, guys.
You only get a little bit before the actual karaoke.
Yeah, also, we're not going to lie, tomorrow is, we don't, I
don't know how long tomorrow's going to be, because it's
heavily dependent on, it's going to be, tomorrow's going to
be heavily dependent on, like, how, how lucky we are when it
comes to, like, if there's shitty teams if they're shitty
teams that's going to be participating the apex legends
challenges circuit and stuff like that so like the thing is
we didn't practice wig tempo and i have not had a single
practice session together i talked about this yesterday on
the jp on the jp tournament thing but like wig fucking
apparently like he he passed out yesterday and never checked
his internet
his text messages um because we were trying to fucking we're
like where is he because we were supposed to have a practice
session yesterday off stream and i was gonna be off stream
and then and then today this morning he messaged us and was
like sorry i was so up man i was like i was like i was like
guys are we gonna be okay
way we're gonna lose the first round.
There's like golden plot players in there.
And I'm like, I'm like, bro, and then Wiggle was like, but
it would be so fucking funny, though.
And I'll be like, but I get to end this early.
Now you're each like, but it would be so fucking funny.
And I'm like, yeah, it would be so funny.
I didn't get to leave early.
So, um next week um we're gonna have two you know how we're
like oh we have one content warning we're gonna have two
content warning streams so i hope you guys won't be too
tired for the content warning stuff because uh next week we
have two content warning streams with two different groups
um the first group will be like j uh will be um um and jp
slash like uh uh chinese centric so like uh i'm collabing
with uh the first content warning stream will be with with
Ditto Hiro Hiro Hiro from and uh you might recognize her
name actually Hiro and um who was it the another one uh
Na-chan uh so Hiro and Na-chan are from Billy Billy and then
you know Ditto and I are YouTube Twitch so like uh it's
gonna be like fun trying to like communicate with everybody
um so that's gonna be the first content warning stream and
then the second content warning stream will be with uh it's
gonna be with uh snuffy lime and han han build uh so that's
the that's the second uh content warning stream one is gonna
be on friday and i think one is on thursday and the other
one's on the first one will be on thursday the second one
will be on saturday so that is the the double content
warning stream that's gonna be the collapse for next week um
That's going to be the collab, two, because, you know, I
usually schedule one to two collabs per week.
And that's going to, I know I actually put two content
warning streams, but I was just like, you know what?
I want to be able to play with all the different people, you
know?
I want to be able to hang out with a bunch of different
people next week.
So I set up two content warning streams.
Okay, shadow of Colossus.
Also, next week, we're going to...
Can I say bring back?
I guess, like, I mean, I guess.
Other than shadow of Colossus, for members, for members, I'm
bringing back the commissions are open.
I'm going to draw your icon horribly.
But if you've, like, commissioned me before, the draw your
icon horribly, if you could, like, let me know, like, tell
me what you let me know.
Like, I'm going to make a members post and just, just tell
me if you commissioned me before, it still stands.
Because if I haven't drawn your icon yet, it still stands.
Like, obviously, I don't have access to, like, the archive
of it anymore.
But, like, if you commissioned me for an icon, um, if
you're, and you're from the, from before, the before four
times, don't worry, in the members post, just fucking, like,
like, find a way.
to let me know we're gonna do honor system because i know
you dragoons have honor right like
you guys you guys have honor right we're doing a sequel i
just so have we're back by popular demand
yeah anyway so i'm bringing that back next week if you
haven't got an icon for me and i'll keep it open for future
for new dragoons too so uh for new dragoons as well if you
guys want an icon It will be open for that as well.
Let's see, what else?
What else do I want to update you guys on?
I think that's like majority of my updates.
I think like next week is a bit more chill because of the
fact that I'm not doing as much next week.
It's just collabs.
There's not really any events or stuff I'm participating in
or anything.
I still can't believe Twitch asked me to headline a Roblox
Twitch rivals.
I think that's like the funniest shit ever.
I thought that was so, I thought that was like, so fucking
funny that, uh, that like, Twitch was like, do you want to,
do you want to, like, be the headline for Roblox?
And I was like, bro, that's so fucking funny, I'm down.
I'm so, I'm so fucking, I'm so fucking down.
Also, um, um, bro, I'm having the worst time with customs.
Like, I told you guys, Like, I know all of you guys are
like, oh my god, PC fun.
Doki, PC fun.
Like, I was supposed to have Customs been holding my PC,
man.
I was like, oh my god, yay, PC.
I was going to be, like, so hyped because I'll be like,
guys, finally after you complained about my PC, my new PC,
it's been stuck in Customs.
Please, I checked the tracking every fucking day.
I check the tracking every fucking day and it's still in the
goddamn warehouse like release my PC
every day I check the fucking customs so yes the reason why
my PC is still fucked up is because um it's because you know
they they're I'm waiting I'm wait don't worry guys I'm
waiting I'm waiting just like all of you
Fucking Canada, man.
Oh, also, I wanted to talk about this.
But, like, did you guys know you can cheese gotcha now?
I did not realize this at all.
But apparently, like, people have figured it out.
You can cheese, like, blind.
Not, like, digital gotcha.
But, like, blindbox gotcha.
You know, like, those, like, merch, like, figure gotcha.
I want to give you guys a little life hack.
And, like, so, like, if you want to get a blindbox, or like
a figure or anything if you look underneath the if you look
at the box's serial numbers it's like uh different numbers
and stuff so like the serial numbers underneath or like any
numbers that's on a box or like any on the like blind box
and stuff correlates to specific figure or like specific
items so like you don't have to it's not random it's
actually not random i think i i learned that on a youtube
short I learned that from YouTube shorts guys
But like basically If you so you don't get You don't have to
be blind You don't have to It won't be blind It's real It's
actually real If you want to do If you want to like do like
IRL gotcha Or like figure gotcha And stuff like that Like
blind boxes all the code there's like just like the codes
correlate to the figure so like if you don't want you're
worried they're gonna get like duplicate if you're worried
you're getting duplicate you can like just like look at the
boxes underneath and then like just make sure it's just the
different numbers so you don't have to you won't get like a
double double blind box um will there be a discord server
for the dragoons to hang out with each other and get doki
scuff updates on the PC customs of the future McDowell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, there's unofficial Discord.
I just need you guys, regarding Discord, I know a lot of
people are always asking me, like, oh, Doki, when will you
ever have, like, a Discord server?
I'm never going to have an official Discord server.
I know this is, like, a really a Twitch thing, but, like, my
substitute for a Discord server is, like, YouTube members.
The reason why I don't have a Discord server is because like
i learn um when you have when you have like okay like uh i
know like when i first started when i was like you know four
years ago i did have my own discord server four years ago
but i was like really small i was a really small streamer
and i was on twitch i got i was on twitch so um like it's
more known for like twitch streamers to have discord servers
but the reason why i don't do that i don't do that now um on
youtube uh i use my member stream as like the equivalent of
a do post like updates i do post updates i do post like um
um like uh you know like i do like exclusive streams on
members and stuff like that but the reason why is that um i
think like a year ago um i joined some i think like a year
and a half ago i joined somebody's like official server like
uh for a collab i think like you guys might remember this
this is like old lore um and then messaging me and sending
me friend requests uh to that account and like i was like
wait this is not smart for me that's why i don't i don't
want to have i don't do official discord service because
like it's just gonna mess up my discord even more i get like
every day i wake up to like
wake up to like 16 plus work messages every day from like
different people and i really cannot have that get cleared i
hate right i like i really cannot like have more messages
and friend requests it's also the reason why also is because
like my friend like um i also like don't really uh uh close
my friend requests and stuff um or like not close i i make
sure my my friend request like it's still like private in
some way for friend request but like it's not like super
closed because like um when i i do like work business stuff
like behind the scenes work stuff i'd just be like just add
me i'll just be like just add me because it's just easier
and i need to be sure that like uh uh just need to be sure
that my communication with like people when it comes to
business things would be okay
Why don't I separate account?
Because logging on and off for two I don't like dealing with
I mean, I used to deal with more than one account But like,
it's just simpler with Everything in one area for me Because
I already have a lot of stuff going on That's why That's why
I don't have an official server An official Discord server
Because a lot of my communication With work stuff and
business stuff Is on Discord It's not I don't have a slack
or anything anymore So it's all on it's mostly on discord
and email So it's just so much easier just not being on an
official server
Um Uh but we do have fan servers We do have fan servers
though Uh so if you guys like Are still want to join like a
A dokeybird fan server That's still they do a lot of
projects I know they do a lot of projects They did a Stinger
project recently, but on April Fuzz, I just, I was just so
busy that I haven't, I haven't like retweeted it or added my
Stingers, but it's so cute.
Did you guys see it?
They did like a Stinger project.
Oh my god.
Let me see if I can look it up.
I don't try to remember what it was called.
Okay, Stinger, Stinger, Dragoon.
Is that it?
Okay, don't keep bird.
Maybe that's it.
I'm pretty sure my fucking mods will find this faster than
me.
I found it!
Guys, it's so cute!
Wait, is this an introduction on how...
This is a guide on how to do it.
Guys, look at this.
Okay, never mind.
My mod did it.
I don't have to do it.
Nice.
My mod did the job for me.
Yay!
Don't worry, next stream.
or not next stream, the stream after the next stream,
because I'm too fucking...
The next stream is, like, challenger circuit, so, like, I
really don't think I have the energy to add.
To add...
Add this thing here by then.
Oh, like, I really don't have the energy.
I'm really excited.
There's so many stuff going on every...
Every day.
There's a lot of, like, events...
That are, like, being planned.
There's a lot of...
um there's a lot of collaborations there's a lot of like
business deals and stuff being planned and everything and
i'm so excited when it all finally goes like once things
start going live i'm i'm super excited i wish i could do
more projects for you dragoons too like just just solely for
you dragoons type deal like like in the past um and
obviously a lot of those because I need to build like the
infrastructure for everything and like building the
infrastructure for everything and building a lot of stuff to
like be able to create new content and create like new
things for dragons.
And it's taking time.
It takes time.
But what are you guys looking forward to?
Like what would you guys like to see or like to have?
Like the Minecraft server for members, They said it'll take
a few more weeks.
A few more weeks to do.
Um.
And.
Uh.
It's just like.
We just.
It just takes time.
It takes a lot of time.
To build everything up.
Oh my gosh.
My energy is slowly dying.
I think my adrenaline is worrying off.
My.
my my adrenaline um is like is like slowly fucking wearing
off after after everything i'm just super chill now
everything's shutting down i think it's also because i
didn't get a lot of sleep i didn't get a lot of sleep i took
a nap before the jp tournament and then i had to work a
little bit and then i took another nap again and then i and
then after that nap i stayed up to I worked for like four
hours straight for the karaoke stuff like the last minute
prep for the my pilot My pilot test for the karaoke
So I'm fucking I'm trying But anyway, this is a short after
party It's a really short after party, I apologize, but I
realize I'm crashing right now I'm crashing I like at this
point I'm like oh no the crash dokey's feeling the crash
right now she's sinking um but thank you everybody i really
enjoyed uh hanging out with all you guys today and uh and i
really enjoyed like you know having that fun karaoke session
with everybody and um i hope you guys enjoyed the work
everyone put into it and I hope you enjoyed the fucking
scuff too the enormous amount of scuff there but you guys
all have fun and that's all that matters I'm gonna go pass
out I'm gonna eat dinner and pass out I wanted to have a
longer chat up with all of you but I think I'm actually my
energy level is like skydiving right now it's actually going
through it's actually nose diving but thank you as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move out to
get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
because we all deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye